hi
everybody I'm Tesla DUIs and I'm really
excited to be here today to tell you all
about solving a secure geocoding problem
that hardly anybody has so you might
think from the title of my talk that I'm
someone who's overly concerned with the
precise locations of things but in
reality I plac a lot more value on the
journey
so today I'm going to tell you about my
journey of getting from one place in
data science learning to another place
that was relatively further along
through the task of creating a secure
code-free
geocoder so first of all why build a
secure code-free geocoder well as my
puppy is proudly telling you here I work
at Fox Chase Cancer Center and I'm a
geospatial data analyst there so I do
things like this I characterize cancer
burden by neighborhood this is in
Philadelphia and in this case looking at
lung cancer then I do the same thing
with cancer risk so in this case we're
looking at smoking Behavior and the
density of tobacco retailers and then I
use that to inform interventions in this
case we're looking at tobacco treatment
participants um for our smoking
cessation program basically I'm arguing
that targeted cancer prevention efforts
depend on geocoded patient data so
geocoding is the process of turning a
text address into a Geo geographically
referenced coordinate system like
latitude and longitude and there are
many ways to do this most people can use
one of these tools but the thing about
doing this with patient data is that you
have to be really careful because an
address is an individual identifier so
we can't send that over a server at
least the most conservative Health
researchers are not going to send that
over a server for data security concern
there are a few options that are secure
for geocoding but they tend to be clunky
expensive and or require coding so this
is a data science conference why is
coding an issue here well while I am the
only geospatial Analyst at Fox Chase
Cancer Center I'm not the only one
interested in using geocoded data
normally the next step after geocoding
is that we link the geocodes with some
area level measures of social
determinants of Health which can be
defined as the place the environments in
which we live work and
play so I'm going to give you a few
examples of other folks at Fox Chase who
are interested in using this type of
data we have clinical researchers who
want to know whether socioeconomic
status um has any association with
treatment outcomes in their patients we
have a multidisiplinary team right now
who's working on increasing diversity in
our clinical trials and want help with
focusing their Recruitment and education
programs and which Community Partners we
should engage in this effort we have
leaders of cancer prevention and control
interventions like our mobile mamography
unit and our patient navigation programs
who want to make sure we're prioritizing
and serving residents in the highest
risk areas and finally our leaders and
administrators of the cancer center are
required to report back to the National
Cancer Institute how well we serving the
residents in our designated catchment
area whether they're representative uh
our patients are representative of that
catchment area and how we're addressing
disparities So currently what happens is
that these um types of inquiries go to
my fantastic boss and then they're
passed on to me like data requests and
on one hand it's really awesome that I
get to support this really impactful
work at Fox Chase and I also got to to
thinking that if I could give
researchers and administrators at Fox
Chase a tool to be a bit more
independent um and geocoding and
potentially linking that patient data
with um common measures from area level
measures that I would be freed up to do
some of the more advanced spatial
analyses that I'm interested in like
when I presented this um machine
learning project that I did on early
onet coloral cancer so I wanted to
create a code-free secure geocoding
application for researchers and
administrators working with patient data
and I actually workshopped this idea
quite a bit with my fantastic boss Dr
Shannon Lynch and her collaborator Dr
Kevin Henry and actually because of
those two individuals I'm going back to
school now for my PhD in
geography thank
you um so I took a class last semester
on geospatial application development
and it was a project-based class we had
to be in group projects and I presented
this as an idea on the first day of
class and quickly two of my classmates
joined my group so we sat in the back of
the classroom while other groups were
forming and I talked about my ideas for
how we would approach this in R and uh
right before we left the classroom the
professor told us that we had to use
Python based
Solutions so this is where I need to
tell you that I've always been a bit of
a
rebel and in fact uh as this newspaper
clip tells you I was the only girl in my
all girls private Catholic High School
who rode a motorcycle from a different
County to school every day and what the
newspaper doesn't tell you is that on my
lunch break I used to get back on my
motorcycle and ride through the convent
behind the school and through the paved
rose gardens and wait for the nuns to
come out and yell at
me so when my professor told me an our
lover that I had to use Python based
solution I immediately went home and uh
started coding it up in
R so I will argue that this wasn't just
an act of rebellion I just as in my um
teenagerhood I really needed to explore
the world in a mode that felt freeing to
me and assert myself as an independent
being um similarly in this
project I needed to deeply understand
conceptually what I was trying to do in
a language that I understood and knew
well so the first phase of this project
is do you build understanding with tools
that you know this is what it looked
like for me in R I started with an
address and then I Ed the Tigers package
to pull down all of the streets for that
count within which the address resided
and this is important because um this
county is the only information that I
sent to a remote server and that's not
individually identifiable information
from there I use deer to filter down to
the correct zip code Stringer to match
on street name deeper again to get down
to the line segment that included the
number of the address and then I took a
a the centroid of that final line
segment using SF and this is a crude
geocode but I would argue at least in an
urban setting it's sufficient next I can
use tidy senses to pull in the sensus
tracks again and Link it um spatially to
that point and tidy sense sensus again
to pull in areial level measures of
interest and then I do everybody's
favorite oh oh sorry then I have this
result which is an address with the
latitude and longitude and a linked area
level measure of Interest then I do
everybody's favorite and stick it in a
for Loop and this was my r geocoder as I
iterate over addresses I'm getting a
bigger data frame with all the linked
data so while this worked um there were
several problems with this first
addresses had to be an exact match so if
there wasn't a W for West Main Street
there just wouldn't be a match at all
there's no name regularization built
into this I could have done it I didn't
do it second my R environment got way
too big way too fast if I was including
multiple counties in that initial data
set I'm pulling down those line files
which are really big for every single
County and it starts to get bogged down
third this is definitely not code free
it worked for me but it wasn't something
I could extend to um the other
researchers and administrators at Fox
Chase and fourth it wasn't a python
based solution and we did for a moment
consider just translating it to Python
and turning it in but the uh other three
issues would have still remained so if
my teens were characterized by riding a
motorcycle through the convent then my
20s were characterized by trying to
shove my triathlon bike into the back of
my Mini Cooper so in my 20s I was really
into triathlons finally gotten a
four-wheeled vehicle after moving out to
the east coast and um I would spend my
Sundays driving my bike out to a place
where I could ride for 50 miles at a
time with very little car traffic and
then I'd get back to my car and
inevitably I'd be hot and tired and
dehydrated and I'd have a hard time
fitting my bike back into the Mini
Cooper so I would call my husband and
tell him first of all like I'm done with
my ride I survived and then talk to him
as I tried shoving the bike into the
Mini Cooper and I'd tell him what I was
trying you know I put the other seat
down I took the front wheel off and and
he might suggest something like why
don't you try putting at rear wheel
first or you know and and sometimes that
would help but usually just the process
of me talking about what I was trying
would give me an idea of what to try
next and eventually I'd get the back of
the Mini Cooper shut and I'd be on my
way so this next phase of the building a
code-free geocoder was very similar to
that we had a lot of tools that we ended
up using and on my team none of us had
any experience with any of these before
we started so we started out by just
like going home each picking one trying
to become an expert on it coming back
talking to each other about what we
learned and then slowly starting to
puzzle these different things together
so that's the next phase using the talk
TR method to iterate L puzzle new tools
together we started out with this um
this tutorial by Michelle Tobias which I
appreciated both for the technical
expertise but also for the validation
that this was really hard and confusing
and took a long time um and even with
that tutorial we spent many nights on
Zoom looking at pages of failure
messages but eventually we did come up
with something that worked and this is
how it worked so first we have a shell
script that starts a Docker container
you have to have Docker desktop already
installed on your computer but it
doesn't need to be open or running the
shell script will start the docker
container and put a postgress SQL
database on it then we have another
shell script that will P pull the
relevant line files with postris and
store them on that post SQL database and
this screenshot here is um hard to see
but we have a a file in there that
updates every time you pull new County
Line files so that the next time you run
it you don't pull those same county line
files again and the data persists in
your Docker
database um and again this is the only
information that we're sending to a
remote server is the
county next we have post functions to
geocode against the database so postes
has a geocoding function already and it
normally sends the address over a server
but instead we're using our Docker
database as the server so we're
directing the data to our local Docker
database and it's never going over a
server so we um are coding this up with
a python function and finally we created
an interface with QT designer and linked
the whole thing up with python and this
is a very basic basic user interface um
but it does have a couple options you
can name your input file designate your
output file and then you can pick
between having your output be a CSV or a
shape file you can choose to have your
points jittered which means just like
randomly moved um within certain bounds
from the true latitude and longitude and
then you could add the social
determinants of Health Data at the
census track level or
not okay so if my teens were
characterized by riding a motorcycle
through the convent and my 20s were
characterized by shoving a bicycle into
the back of the Mini Cooper my 30s how
many people have experienced their 30s
in here okay all right so my 30s have
been characterized by a bit of
compromise so uh when I was pregnant
with my second daughter my husband and I
decided it was time to give up on any
idea that we would ever be cool again
and we went ahead and bought a
minivan it was very sad we had to let go
of some ego but it was the most
functional choice you know it would work
for our family but I believe that you
should really own where you are when you
have to make that type of decision so we
went ahead and got the license plate
van with five
A's and the only time that is backfired
is when my kid got a point off on a
spelling test for putting too many A's
in the word van in first grade and she
tells me it was a joke but the teacher
obviously didn't get it so but she only
put four a so she was right to get a
point off
cuz um so this phase of this project
also required some compromise uh and
we'll get to that but and in doing so we
I had to you know prioritize
functionality over flare much like
getting the
minivan but before we had to compromise
we're actually feeling quite good about
where we were so one week before the
final was due we gave a demo to our
class I'm going to walk you through that
now
so the first demo we're exporting a CSV
of true points with the census track
variables attached now this might be a
little hard to see but we're starting
down here with a CSV that has two
columns one is just an address ID and
the other one is the addresses all in
one column and we hadn't packaged this
into an executable file yet um so we're
pressing run right up here from the
spider interface and then it pops open
our guey we can nav at to the CSV of
addresses designate our output we want a
CSV not jittered with the social
determinants of Health Data at census
track level press okay and it gives us
this um output that it's it's telling us
that it's pulling those County Line
files and then we have the file pop up
where we designated we can open this up
and we see that we do indeed have a
latitude and longitude and importantly
that rating for how good of a match it
is
so I have a PO Box in here as a test it
has a really poor rating and that's what
we want to see and then we have the area
level social determinance of Health
measures on there in our second demo we
have a shape file of jittered points and
the census track variables attached
again we're going to go ahead and press
run put in our um file designate the
output we want a shape file we do want
it jittered this time and again we're
attaching the census track variables
press run
this time it's not pulling those County
Line files because we already did it 2
minutes ago and remember the data
persists in our Docker container so it
doesn't have to call it again this time
it's telling us that it has to shorten
the column names when it's exporting a
shape file which if you do geospatial
stuff you're familiar with not a big
deal we can open up um qgis Now call in
that shape file and indeed we see that
that jittered point is just slightly off
from the true latitude and longitude all
right so we were feeling pretty good our
professor was impressed our classmates
were impressed like we thought we were
pretty awesome but uh then we still had
to package it up into a downloadable
executable that somebody could click on
their desktop and it would pop open our
goey and we ran into some problems so
this is our group chat the day before
the final was due and it turned out that
the python module that I was using to
calculate the census track level
variables was causing an issue when we
were packaging it into an executable so
I had to just comment out all of that
code and say okay well we're not turning
in you know that that was like a nice to
have right then we did get it into an
executable file but um it wouldn't run
when you double clicked on it from
download it would only run if you go to
the terminal and tell it to run from the
terminal which is not entirely code free
but the final was due and we had to turn
in what we had had and so um so that's
what we did we turned it in and this is
where being a journey person really
comes in handy right because even though
I didn't get all the way where I wanted
to get with this geocoder I would argue
that by building conceptual
understanding with tools that I knew
well using the talk try method to
iteratively experiment and puzzle things
together and knowing when it's time to
compromise and by doing so prioritizing
functionality over flare I definitely
progressed in my data science Learning
Journey and not only did I progress in
that Journey even though it's not ready
for prime time I did create something
that I can use at work so I recently
geocoded 3,000 Pat patient addresses 85%
of them were geocoded with the python
based solution which is pretty good like
it's what would you would expect for
patient data and then I got an extra 5%
by running it the ones that didn't
geocode through the r geocoder
and the thing is the journey continues
so I can't tell you uh I'm not 40
yet so I can't tell you what the next
phase or lesson is going to be but I can
tell you this on days that I drive to
class or to the office I drive a hybrid
and at work I just got a data science
undergrad intern to help me continue
building this out so I hope that the
phase feels really efficient but you
know either way I'm just happy that the
journey continues thank
[Applause]
you